welcome to Hannity and this is a Fox's
alert and we are broadcasting tonight
from the 193rd special operations wing
at the Air National Guard base in
Middletown Pennsylvania where earlier
today President Trump he took his
message directly to you the American
people by giving a major speech on his
Reagan s tax cuts and his tax reform
plan now right before that speech the
president joined us for an exclusive
interview we discussed his tax proposal
the fake news media the NFL's national
anthem controversy the Russia
investigation and so much more let's
take a look
[Music]
very good my second interview since
you've been president you guys want to
start with good news you don't get a lot
of good news in the media you don't get
so much the markets up 25% since you
were one you tweeted this out that
nobody in the media brings it up so I
said you know what I'm gonna bring it up
tonight five point two trillion dollars
and wealth created we have the lowest
unemployment rate in 16 years we have
the look the best labor participation
rate in seven years and the best the
lowest number of people on food stamps
in seven years really well I'm loving it
I'm doing a job for the people and
people are seeing that and I'm so proud
of the five point two trillion dollars
of increase in the stock market now if
you look at the stock market that's one
element but then we have many other
elements the country we took it over a
toe 20 trillion as you know the last
eight years they borrowed more than it
did in the whole history of our country
so they borrowed more than ten trillion
dollars right and yet we picked up five
point two trillion just in the stock
market possibly picked up the whole
thing
in terms of the first nine months in
terms of value so you could say in one
sense we're really increasing values and
maybe in a sense we're reducing debt but
we're very honored by it we're very very
happy with what's happening on Wall
Street you came back to Pennsylvania I
know you've been in Wisconsin in
Michigan and Ohio and North Carolina
because a lot of people still need
opportunity in jobs you really here
you're gonna be talking at length about
your economic plan that's right let's
talk about it okay well first of all
it's a massive tax cut and you know it's
a reform but it's a mess
you know when we first introduced it and
for years they talked about tax reform I
said the problem with the word reform
nobody understands what it means because
reform could mean you're going to raise
taxes this is the largest tax cut in the
history of our country it is incredible
it's gotta put people to work so right
now showing we are the highest taxed
nation in the world and we're going to
be now down in the lower rung in terms
of taxes a family can get and a business
can get especially a subchapter S you
know you're doing different kinds of
things with your businesses some people
run it individually but you can get as
much as a 40% tax reduction again it's
the largest tax reduction in the history
of let's go through it so this is
important I mean how many there's no two
accountants that can give you the same
liability to the government if you give
them the same information that's how
complicated the tax code is it's you
want to drop seven brackets to three
we're gonna drop actually if you look at
it because we have a zero bracket
because a lot of people pay zero so we
really have four and they had eight so
it's really eight down to four we're
cutting it in half and a lot of a lot
are taxed below the $12,000 mark and
$24,000 for family they're taxed at zero
after that it goes to 12% from 15% and
you know the Democrats told a very
terrible fib they said that they read
the bracket so that the brackets were
inverted and if you read it that way but
that's not the way it goes and we've
been praised for the amount of money the
middle class this is really what I'm
looking for for the middle class I call
it the working people and the working
people are going to get a massive tax
break and corporations and companies and
small companies are going to get
large-scale tax relief and they'll be
able to keep compete with anybody in the
world which is what we need you said the
corporate rate which is so important
you said 20% of your max so right now
we're 35% that many corporations are
paying 40s and 42 and because they have
state taxes and city taxes and their
taxes so many different directions you
know what they do they leave the country
and they fire everybody and they're gone
and they never come back now we have
companies moving back into the country
we have you saw last week auto companies
are announcing that they're going to
build plants back in the United States
that hasn't happened for years and
they're moving back like and not just
because of the taxes tax is so important
but they're seeing enthusiasm we have
the highest enthusiasm level in 28 years
of summer for manufacturing for all of
the different things that we talk about
but for business basically it's
enthusiasm everybody's enthused about
our country so we're very honored by it
and I am really honored by the folks in
this room and by the way the trucker's
we love the trucker's I the top 10% pay
70% of the tax bill the bottom 50% pay -
yeah of the total income tax rate why is
the the there were multinational
corporations that have part trillions of
dollars in tapping countries that offer
them better tax relief you're trying to
incentivize those trillions to come back
here with the low repatriation rate how
low will that be and how much do you
think you can bring back into the United
States and what does it mean ok so right
now you have probably and nobody knows
the exact number because it's I actually
think it's much higher than people
understand but it'll probably be over
three trillion dollars is outside of our
country and our companies and they just
can't get it back
they're trying but they can't get it
back number one it's a bureaucratic mess
number two the tax rate is so high it
doesn't make sense so what they do is
they invested in Europe and other places
where the money is and I'll tell you
what they do also they leave the country
because the money becomes so much and so
valuable to them
that they leave the country our country
to go and get their money so they leave
the country and they fire everybody now
what we're doing is we're lowering the
rate so they can bring it back in we're
giving them a shot to bring all that
money it's all going to come back in
it's going to come back in immediately
it's going to be more than three
trillion dollars probably we're looking
at a 10% rate it may be around that
number may be a little higher maybe a
little lower but it's going to be right
around that number probably 10 percent
and right now what it is is thirty five
percent plus now who's gonna bring money
back when you have to pay by the time
you finish almost half of your money in
tax so you're never going to bring it
back so we're gonna have that money come
back in it's gonna put people to work so
fast and the money itself is gonna go to
work very fast and you know say what you
want about Democrats and Republicans for
years years and years everybody's
wanting to do then you have trillions of
dollars outside of our country offshore
and the Democrats wanted it back the
Republicans wanted it back everybody
wanted it back and they couldn't do it
they couldn't get a deal we're gonna do
a deal and we're putting it down as part
of our tax cuts but one of the things
some people have brought up
every time I talk to tune in to anybody
else in the media except Fox there are
tax cuts with a wealthy now the rate for
some people go goes down but if you live
in a state like New York or Illinois in
New Jersey or California it won't be
able to deduct your local or state
income tax in other words if you elect
politicians that want to raise taxes
you're going to pay the penalty so
that's not really true that this is a
tax cut for the wealthy as they're
portraying it what is your answer to
that well you know you have some really
well-run states that have very little
borrowings don't have no borrowing but
that very little borrowing and it's
unfair that a state that is well run is
really subsidizing states that have been
horribly mismanaged I won't use names
but we understand the names but there
are some states that have hundreds of
millions and billions of dollars in
borrowing and it's unfair that those
states really are being subsidized by
states like Indiana and Iowa and I mean
I could name many states I could
probably name three-quarters of them
they're so well-run and they're being
penalized they're being penalized and
it's not fair and so what we're doing is
we're showing that now with all of that
the tax cuts are so steep that the
people in every state benefit but it's
finally time to say hey make sure that
your politicians do a good job of
running your state otherwise you're not
going to benefit you know you look at a
place like Florida it's really well run
away Rick Scott and you know by Governor
Scott he's done a great job and so many
people have done a great job and those
are the people that frankly should the
people that had the intelligence to
elect them should really benefit and
that's what we're doing we're creating
an incentive and the doubt of the bottom
line there look the tax cut is massive
we're bringing it down to 20% we're
bringing it down to 12% for individuals
we'll bring it down to zero in some
cases if it's a family it's below
$24,000 anything below 24,000 is zero
and look it's as I just said it's the
biggest tax cut in the history of our
country and it's
the spur growth and it's going to keep
our companies here our companies are
leaving because the taxes are so high
but you also a big part of it you've
already done and that is you ended a lot
of the Obama era regulations especially
in in industries like energy and coal
there seems to be you have a very strong
commitment you just recently went
forward with Anwar you put in place
opportunities for the coal mining
industry fracking we do have an
opportunity to be energy independent and
there seems to be millions of
high-paying career jobs for people
available if that decision is made how
big a part is that for the economic
recovery well I have done so much and
Scott Pruett who has APA has done
incredibly you saw yesterday at a news
conference on coal and his whole concept
was coal is back it's back and the
miners are working again mines are
opening in the state of Pennsylvania and
I love this state because I happen to go
to college in the state I know it very
well and they also one missile you also
won Pennsylvania right is he going to
win Pennsylvania 2022
by the way incredible people incredible
state and I did win Pennsylvania I
worked hard in Pennsylvania and frankly
I understand what pencil Pennsylvania is
about work these are working deeds of
people that want to work but we're
opening minds
we're opening minds in the state of
Pennsylvania we're opening minds other
places you know coal is a very and I
call it clean coal they have technology
today that's so incredible what they can
do with a piece of coal is so incredible
I call it clean coal but it's one of our
great resources one thing that I'm very
proud of the state of West Virginia last
month it was one of the highest
increases percentage increases in GDP
the state of Texas speedin and people
say wait a minute
West Virginia just came in second you
know what that's about
that's about cutting regulations and
letting the people go and mine and I was
so proud of that because West Virginia's
had very tough times and you know they
were overwhelmingly for me Hillary said
she wants to close up industries and she
wants to close up the coal industry and
I'm the opposite so I'm very proud of
that and Pennsylvania likewise before
you arrived here I had an opportunity to
interview a lot of people in this great
crowd and I asked them basically three
different questions what they thought of
you overwhelmingly the oh there's a lot
of support for you here Congress
when I asked them about what was your
answer on Congress what was your answer
on the median we saw what happened with
health care and John McCain this
economic plan sounds a lot to me like
what Reagan did and that created 20
million new jobs and revenues doubled
this is important for your agenda yeah
how do you get this through the Senate
which has not had a good record in the
last 10 long so this will be an even
bigger tax cut than the great Reagan
cuts this will be even more dramatic and
I think it will create even more
incentive but let's talk media is bad
they're really dishonest people these
are very very dishonest people in many
cases in many cases and not all look I
know some reporters I know some
journalists are phenomenal people and
very straight very honest but there's
such dishonesty I mean you know it's
interesting if I was just watching
television you don't know whether or not
because you know you're just watching a
report but when you're the one being
written about you know if it's good or
bad and it's always they try and make it
negative so the media has certain that I
call it fake media it's fake thanks so
much fake news and
[Applause]
people read things they can understand
that so much of it is indeed fake but
with Congress I've got the notes a lot
of them there are a lot of good people
don't forget for health care we had 48
votes
49 votes we had a lot of great
Republicans we need more Republican
senators to be honest with you
but we had a lot of
[Applause]
by the way Lou Barletta as long as we're
on the subject looper I led a great guy
he's running he was an incredible
Congress
and I think I think you're going to have
a tremendous surge for Lou Bella I think
he's going to do a fantastic job and we
do need more Republican senators because
you have a tiny smaller we have 52 to 48
and if a couple of people want to
grandstand or whatever they want to do
all of a sudden because when you have to
get almost every single vote you need 51
so you have to get at least 50 because
the vice president Mike Pence great guy
right great all of these people to
people decide they want to do something
for whatever reason in some cases it is
it's grandstanding now all of a sudden
you don't have health care but we're
gonna get it anyway we have it we have
the numbers now we're gonna get that and
tomorrow I'm signing something that's
going to be incredible that I can do
myself in 1974 there was good has to do
with we're gonna have great healthcare
across state lines people can buy will
cost the government nothing you'll go
out private insurers are going to give
you incredible health care and I'll tell
you what this will take and I can sign
it myself I don't need anybody I would
have done it earlier except I was hoping
that they were going to put this through
and I'd have it in the bill but we're
signing tomorrow a health care package
that will cover I don't know people say
30 percent people say 25 percent and
some people say could be 50 percent it's
going to cover a large percentage of the
people that we're talking about truckers
would benefit say you're not a perfect
fit
right
right the truckers will will benefit l4
Merkel but this will be fantastic now
would have done this immediately but we
were hoping for the health care so I
think health care is gonna pass I can't
imagine the largest tax cut for people
in our history not passing but I have to
say this I've met some great great
people that are Republicans and I've met
some great people frankly I've met some
good people not necessarily great people
that are Democrats and I actually think
we'll have Democratic support from a few
people you do I do I do believe that
we'll have some Democrat support we'll
get a few votes maybe you know it's
interesting the one thing with the
Democrats they stay together like glue
they're lousy politicians and their
policies are terrible but they do stick
together
we have great policies but the
Republicans tend not to be as unified
some people you saw and heard bob Corker
yeah john mccain wasn't there even
though I can run I can run a hundred ad
showing John McCain I'm gonna repeal and
replace Obamacare he vote you wouldn't
even vote to just repeal it yeah I know
so that's got to be frustrating and
disappointing well we thought we had it
the first time we thought it was done
and we thought John was with us and all
of a sudden out of nowhere he voted
again so we end up losing by one vote
but here's the thing we're gonna get it
and you know I always say never give up
never ever quit we don't quit we're
there we'll one vote
[Applause]
but we have to wait we have to wait for
a little while we're going to do the
Texas first hopefully we get that we
need 51 votes if we get it done by the
end of the year I hope so I mean who's
gonna vote against this our country is
losing businesses losing jobs we have a
1% GDP now I have to tell you for the
last quarter 3-letter three percent
three two and actually three two they
adjusted it upward what a nice sound
that is are they playing that for you or
for me they're playing that in honor of
his ratings did you see how good he's
beating everybody I think they'll be
higher tonight I'm going to guess it so
the fact is that we really were really
rockin we have 3.2 now this next quarter
coming up I believe would have even been
better you know we haven't hit threes in
a long time so I guess it was ultimately
determined it was 3.2 because they
adjusts upward but we got hit with a few
hurricanes as you probably that'll have
I assume an impact Barack Obama was the
first president in history that never
hit 3% GDP growth in a single year of
his presidency which I think speaks
volumes well you know when I took over
yeah we were in the ones and if we hit
think of this if we hit just one point
if we go up from two to three we pick up
2.5 trillion dollars 2.5 trillion the
Treasury and we pick up millions of job
[Applause]
[Music]